you're such a supportive and loving mom
I saw you out there clapping cheering
them on I even told my producer I was
like I love I love Kendra as a mom and
you know how important is it for you to
have these family date nights it's
extremely important to have these date
nights and I mean come on
I mean I'm probably the coolest mom on
earth right now taking my kids here and
then getting to skate with the
princesses and Mickey Mouse I mean I
think I'm I can be Queens the the best
mom in the world right now I mean I you
know what could cool mom points I'll
along with the holidays right around the
corner what are the plans for you guys
well you know there are a lot of holiday
plans coming up there's a lot in the air
right now but I think kicking it off
here at Disney on Ice is definitely a
good start we got our tree the other day
you know being a being a newly single
mom now is a big deal and I'm still
trying to figure it all out no pun
intended because of the the mingling but
you know are you ready to mingle yet or
you just want to focus right now on
spending time with the kids right now
it's all about the kids nothing beyond
that point so I just want to make sure I
want to survive the holidays make sure
the kids get everything they they want
and more they deserve it and just just
survive no no no no no no that's last
thing on my mind yeah so this this
definitely all this is just my joy right
now for myself and my kids you know no
no kids
none of that that's up Kim you can see
the joy on your face when you you know
hopefully hopefully by New Year's I have
someone but I mean I look on right
around the corner yeah you know or in
your skin will be crying about it a New
Year's kiss will speak it into existence
for both of us when I knew my new year's
resolution for sure to have to have a
kiss on New Year's Eve